jodie aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
docteur maboule sur ipad voilà vous
voyez les juste là on va pouvoir opérer
de la sorte c'est parti ceci est une
blague nul à l'est quand tellement bon
on est là pour quand même opéré après
patients on va l'opérer des yeux sur la
version ipad on a donc deux opérations
exclusives celle des yeux et celle
d'après qui est des dents 1 c'est parti
je veux tu étais ce que viens on va lui
retirer sa ou la ville ouvre les yeux
l'expression n'est pas au derby
messieurs c'est scandaleux attendez les
l'arrière sur ta gauche ne regarde pas
comme ça on est louche mon dieu retire
les lunettes et il est carrément pendant
qu'ils quoi mais il ya clairement un
gros problème pour cette opération pour
on va lui retirer son masque sans être
trop bourrin bien évidemment au marteau
d'accord ceci est impossible
attendez le post it sur le bocal au cas
où quelqu'un de n'est pas au courant que
c'est les yeux il peut peut-être penser
que c'est des litchis donc ok c'est long
et bim
maintenant comment on va retirer ça je
pense que ça va se faire comme ça il
faut y aller catch up
non pas du tout ah non faut pas y aller
par le côté un peu genre comme ça auo
est assez glauque
ah non non on couche pas tomber s'il te
plaît la piquouse nord paris puis par
les cuit on va lui faire descendre un
peu son coup parce que j'ai quand même
fait à peu près une heure de médecine il
ya quelques mois en zone 20 vidéos sur
ce jeu allait sous l'oeil
sous l'oeil vous faire une fois un effet
de levier ça m'a bien j'étais scalp et à
mes yeux ça allait ressort pour sa part
comme ça c'est pas de ma faute
ok et là je peux lui retirer ou pas ses
yeux mais non mais pas du tout quoi
fouille à nu le foyer le tire-bouchon
fait faut y aller ou quoi je comprends
pas alors labat et logos allez tu es
prêt pour la soie nouvel an je crois
qu'est ce qui pourrait nous aider dans
cette situation des cotons tiges ou ça
me plaît ça attendez il ya un petit
bouton dessus aucune est ce que c'est
mais ça va marcher
jet jet [ __ ] mais ces médias locaux à
elle c'est pas bizarre qu'on fait leur
père dans les bordels non mais faut que
je rallume
il a lu pas avec ce qu'il faut ce truc
auquel il s'est passé un truc
voilà donc là il peut observer tout le
bloc opératoire en a que ça c'est
magnifique
voilà armés dans le bouquin et puiseux
voilà ça se trouve il se passe peut-être
quelque chose comme ça dans le bouquin
on va savoir
il ya quasiment plus de sens et ce qu'on
appelle petite sacoche de son à lui
prêté par toisa non on est une bouteille
d'orangina qu'évident
ça dégage à la plage et desseigne à la
création des cieux à l'aimer coupe tard
et j'ai encore plus oui c'est beau mais
c'est super dur à couper ce n'est pas un
tendon c'est un cordon ombilical rires
dans le bloc opératoire
j'ai dit rires d'armor opératoire mais
chaîne arrête de bouger ces genres de
multiples rico et désinfecter une plaie
quand il avait deux ans et demi là je
peux pas eut arraché à la limite c'est
le brand et le 1 peut le comprendre mais
j'ai dit l'oeil mais la faire valser
toys et plus longtemps dans son bocal et
vous allez constater genre qu'est ce que
vous faites dans cette histoire on sert
à rien bah oui je sais bien que je sais
bien
eh ben voilà on a un mec très beau gosse
là un très beau gosse aux allures holly
mignot alors on va lui mettre de
nouveaux yeux up le premier mais non
mais c'était pas ça comme ça oh bah oui
hop il arrive à cacher son oeil
il est fort cet homme est très très fort
il était tellement chaud si bim
alors maintenant on en est aux dents
juste voir cette image ça me donne envie
des piliers un éléphant quoi perform
this transplante alors déjà pourquoi il
a un truc qui vous gâchent des jeux
c'est inadmissible moi j'ai encore envie
d'arracher des dieux pour enlever ce
truc on peut pas le prendre mais baissé
il va encore falloir lui
que tu es la moitié de l'âge ou le
regarder mais [ __ ] je veux juste lui
retirer son masque
non mais comment donner des points de
suture bêtement à quelqu'un hop un bon
dieu on remet tout de suite se massent
pour mais tout de suite ce masque ferme
la bouche ferme ma bouche ou une fourmi
arrivera dedans
une araignée un avion non mais [ __ ]
mais viennent mais [ __ ] mais regarde
rien tout est déformé arrête
allez on va y aller comme ça mais mais
lui mais pas dans la gorge pour juste la
dent très bien non je suppose que
c'était peut être tous du tchèque va les
prendre à elle bien fait lui il n'est
allé on lui refait le nez ça te plait un
oh oui oh oui bob ho oui on y va on y va
au bob bush et aujourd'hui hier comme ça
dégage regarde comme ça dégage dans la
voilà toutes les dents voilà là on tient
un truc moi la saison sinon on était
tellement ignoble que je dirais peut
coupe
yes tâche et toujours cette surprise
horrible à 2 comme à jeumont jour fait
là les habits de rechange des opérations
ah ah ah ça va ah non ça m'étonnerait
même pas qu'ils mangent la tasse toi et
bouge comme ça avec mon bail et ils
mangent les tasses d'ailleurs chez lui
c'est fait c'est pour ça qu'il y en ait
la wii non non non mais ça c'est le
personnage de acheté dans un magasin de
bricolage que salam épique
est ce qu'un médecin a déjà plus de
perfusion comme ça allait je sois faire
je sais j'ai une idée remove protective
dust mac mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être mieux diallo syphilis ou rouge
the damage this voilà donc c'était bien
la perceuse lui en a ri di cu
transplante flotte mi-août is in with
your hands nommé audio dirais que c'est
carrément simple par contre quand tu te
retrouves dans l'opération ça se passe
plutôt comme ça finalement à puisse
rentrer ou pas grossi forme
leur poule mais sept ans est en béton ou
une scie sauteuse pour la coupe et à ne
regarder quoi ces discothèques là dedans
en fait quel genre de chien ont germé
musée cosip coup n'en fout wendel n'est
pas moyen de les attraper à l'est mais
certaines ici ce n'est pas chez vous
allez vous en avez d'expulsion tandem et
si on lui laisse tes dents pourries dans
le fond puis on s'en fout au pendjab
volet on l'a vu à regarder elle croit qu
on la voit pas tu crois que tu es
camoufler la 1 une comme ça ira devant
moi je met dans la bouche au pire un je
ne sais pas qu'elle dormait trou on
attendait mais je peux pas lui en mettre
plein de chaque de dampierre puisse des
maires lui même
non non pas dans la daille non pas dans
quelle est donc qu'ils sont passés sous
très bien massage des dents il ya un
truc non et un truc à faire lors toutes
les dents bien comme ça bien manger et
là hop on mélange tout on mélange tout
j'ai dit trouver votre place mais dame
non pas sur le menton non c'est le
torticolis à mon dieu il se voit en lui
même le coût peut dire [ __ ] de
serpents dégueulasse j'ai réussi à
cacher sa bouche
oh mon dieu c'est la fête allez on
s'amuse on danse un peu comme des gros
beaufs super ono je suis tellement
triste
[Musique]